that's drake's four-year-old son adonis
showing off his impressive basketball
skills the hotline bling rapper posted
this sweet video of his son shooting
hoops to his instagram story i'm excited
about it man talk about following in his
dad's footsteps the 35 year old rapper
is known to show his love for the game
in real life and in his lyrics
in the video adana starts with some
simple dribbling and counting but then
it's go time adonis shoots he scores and
gets mad applause from his pals and
famous dad
[Applause]
it seems the daddy sun pair have been
spending a lot of quality time this year
on christmas the grammy winner shared
this sweet moment with his young son
drake shares adonis who was born in
october 2017 with sophie brousseau this
past fall drake celebrated adonis's
fourth birthday with a race car themed
bash and posted some cute pics to
instagram here they are posing together
in front of an elaborate cake display
and back in may the billboard music
awards the rapper brought his son out on
stage during his acceptance speech after
receiving the artist of the decade award
started
[Music]
started from the bottom now we're here
started from the bottom now my whole
team
while accepting the trophy drake
dedicated the award to his son talk
about a sweet father-son duo who know
how to live it up on stage and on the
court
you